[Music]
so my name is zak cheney and i'm going
to talk to you about formal methods
in their application for trustworthy ai
and as i said this this talk will be
with minimal technicalities so i hope
you don't need a background to
understand it i'm gonna i'm gonna
do a little deviation through a moment
in history of formal methods that that i
think is is uh relevant to uh to what
we're going through now and then i'm
gonna give a global overview of the
discipline uh give a real world example
to to be more a little bit more
practical and finish with some challenge
some of the challenges that we see in
the in the near future
so let's start with what are formal
methods uh generally speaking informal
methods are
based on
math and logic and they are applied to
the validation specification
different steps of the
life cycle of software and hardware
and we use them because they can offer
formal guarantees on the the
requirements of of these systems uh and
and this usefulness is reflected in the
fact that uh more and more standards are
encouraging the use of formal methods in
this development process
so i'm gonna focus on two methods uh two
formal methods in this talk first one is
formal verification uh globally speaking
for modification
you have a you have a
program that is designed to be run on a
set of inputs you have a specification
from for that
for that program
from that you encode them in certain
languages that are uh
let's say adequate for certain tools uh
of formal verification and the goal of
this is if you have a positive answer at
the end you know or you're as sure as
you can be
that
the the
the program satisfies the specification
and if not then you can either
sometimes you have a timeout uh and some
tools can give you a counter example
meaning that they give you an input that
violates the specification
the other method that i'm going to talk
about a bit is property-based testing so
in this
in this
method you you take the specification
and based on that specification you
generate inputs automatically that try
to cover as much as possible that
specification to test your program so
here for example uh we have we have a
partner that said my system uh has to be
uh
it is part of the specification of my
system that it has to be robust to
different uh lighting conditions so
darker and lighter images because it's
used
throughout the day
and so what we did is generate
images with varying degrees of of
lighting conditions and that allowed us
to compare several models that were uh
designed for for that uh that uh problem
uh and see that the orange one is is
much
much
frail to to this type of of the
differences
so now to the moment of history i was
talking about in particular to the end
of the 70s
nice
there's a problem in the slide uh so if
you can't read the uh
the uh the line there the name of the
paper is a social process and proofs of
theorem and programs uh which had this
very provocative quote program
verification is bound to fail uh
needless to say if that were true then
this talk would be half half as long um
and you might think this is an obscure
uh
prophecy from from an unknown paper but
actually the
the people who made this prophecy are
are big names that you unfortunately
can't can't read
uh they're uh
ritual the
middle uh richard lipton and alan perlis
and they all worked at prestigious
universities and one of them was the
knuth prize winner one of them was the
first recipient of the the turin award
so you can imagine the influence that
this paper had on the language uh that
we use in formal methods
uh
and and and
let's say when when a term becomes toxic
when when you associate stigma with the
term then it can influence the
university courses you can improve the
the phd uh subjects that you that the
students choose so it can it can of
course reduce the funding opportunities
because you
you fear of losing credibility if you if
you uh
if you use this type of terms
i didn't put a timer i should have
um
and so you can you can read more about
it in this this very good book that
called mechanizing proof by uh donald
mckenzie it's not non-technical book
it's more of a sociological and
historical look at the evolution of
former methods
um so yeah those who work in ai can
relate to this type of problem because
this is what happened for the ai winters
uh
we didn't reach that probably because
formal methods was never as fashionable
as ai but but we definitely felt the the
the slow movement at some point
fast forward around 20 years and we have
this
seminal uh accident uh it's very
important for the formalistic community
because it's uh one it could have been
avoided if we had used formal methods uh
and two it is the first example of the
large scale usage of former methods in
in a real life system and in particular
apps are contribution which i'll talk
briefly about afterwards
[Music]
and it's also a good example to scare
students so i know there are students of
superior here so
so this the reason i'm talking about
this is to say we have come a long way
so the the the the the the evolution was
very long and we
the former mrs community want to say we
of course i was young at the time but
pharmacists community worked hard to to
achieve these results now uh it is used
in many industrial sectors
some of them are here some of them work
with cea in this subject
because ca along with the academic
community of course
developed tools industry relevant tools
to tackle these problems
and the reason i talk about this is
because with ai all the tools that we
made were specific to human written code
by the way it should probably change the
slide because this is not human written
code i mean it is human written code but
if you write your code like this you get
fired and it's it's
not it's not a way to write
um
but the the the goal of this slide is to
say we we have evolved a lot but we have
evolved
by looking at the type of problems we
needed to to tackle and we adjusted our
tools with regards to that and now we
have
a new challenge
and our tools don't work most of them
don't work so we need to do the work
that we did before
and we know that our uh
there are there are miles and miles
between theory and practice but we also
know that we walked these miles so we we
kind of know the way we're this is why
i'm optimistic because we went through
this already uh the first solvers sat
solvers for example for those who know
the what they died but their solvers
um
weren't as efficient as they are today
they weren't efficient at all actually
uh but today they can handle millions of
constraints and and that happened
because we looked at the problems and we
found uh heuristics we found clever
algorithms to to deal with these
problems and we can do the same for ai
and it's actually started
just in the past few years we have more
than 20 tools that uh that uh seen the
light of day that were published
and each paper that's published
increases the
scalability and efficiency
the good ideas that are developed in one
tool are
redeveloped in others so that all the
community can advance
we have we have the niche creation in
the in the sense of some solvers get
specialized in some type of activation
functions some type of models etc
there is an adaptative pressure in on
the form of formal methods uh community
because as as was said before the the
field of ai is very fastly changing
um so we need to be to be able to always
keep up
and this effervescence is reflected in
the number of the of the
avenues of publication that that were
organized recently
some of them are specific to formal
methods like the
fourth and the fifth here uh some of
them were co-organized by cea the first
one was also organized with with indriya
and in addition to these
we have
of course we are welcome to publish
formal methods papers applied to ai
informal methodical
conferences workshops symposium etc
so now after this global view of the
discipline
um
so i always fail validation is a three
players game in the sense of you have uh
on the one side the object to certify
which is developed by the by the the
developer or the the client or the
industrial partner
you have the methods and the tools
these are developed by us
and then in the middle is where most or
a good portion of the interaction
happens it's it's where we we have to
meet together and and we have to lay
down what is it exactly that we're
trying to prove
what is the the validation process that
the the partner needs to follow and how
can we
formally specify these properties in
order to be able to to deal with them
uh so i'm going to talk about the
property the specification problem that
we have in in ai right now
uh
and the the properties can be widely
separated into the first ones are what
is uh formally specifiable and these are
the the the type of problems where the
inputs have
immediate semantics for example we have
here a an akas which is an air collision
devotion system
that basically
takes as input a distance an angle of
approach a speed etc
and outputs directive to change course
if a collision is about to happen
so here in this problem the the the
terms of the specification
near and approaching from the left etc
are related to
physical properties that are
taken as input from the from the neural
network
and so we can formally specify basically
the whole system and therefore you we
can verify it so this is the ideal uh
the ideal scenario
and you have
sensory inputs which are a bit harder to
tackle
and this is because the semantics of
what is inside an image for example is
not
seen at the level of the pixels of the
encoding doesn't have that semantics
so what you can do is
specify uh properties based on these
pixels so for example you can talk about
the distance from an image to another
image in terms of the number of pixels
that you have to change and how much you
have to change them
but what is inside the image is not um
you can't say for example if i have a
pedestrian because a pedestrian is not a
formerly specified term
and so
for these things what we can do
uh so if we look at the at the
machine learning uh as an example uh
the the problem is is
this i'm trying to be as general as
possible but you have a distribution on
which you want your system to be able to
uh generalize or to to deal with
and so what you're going to do is select
a certain number of inputs from that
distribution and you've got to train
your network on it and ideally what you
want what you would want is for it to
cover as much as possible
of that distribution
um
so of course
ideally it could cover the whole
distribution but that rarely happens uh
so what you want is something like this
but we what we don't want is something
like this meaning the system only knows
what it look what it was trained on
and nothing more
so what you can do here is uh
first ask yourself how it behaves in the
neighborhood of certain selected inputs
and so you pick a distance epsilon
as i said before distance can be the
number of pixels that are changed and
how much they change et cetera
and once you have that distance it is a
form of specification and so you can
prove it you can either verify it
completely you can verify the
neighborhood you can verify that the
system on that neighborhood is well
behaved
which gives you formal guarantees but
can be costly
and then you can also test so based on
that distance you can generate inputs
so you're not covering all the
neighborhood but you can you can you can
try to take as wide as a distribution as
possible this doesn't give you a formal
guarantee on the neighborhood but it is
it can scale much faster and therefore
you can also pick wider distances uh so
why do we do this well it can help you
detect this type of problems that i
talked about before
but if you pass the test if all the
selected data are or if your network is
robust in the neighborhood of all the
data that you selected it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's general
completely right
for the distribution again i'm talking
about sensory input of course if it's a
formally specifiable property then you
can do it
so it doesn't imply this
you can also uh generate data from
acceptable transformation so these are
the tests uh the property based testing
i was talking about for example if you
have images and you want your system to
be robust with regards to
blurry images darkened images etc
you can use this property to generate
images
hopefully what you're trying to do is
cover as much space as possible from the
distribution
again so it's the same the same with the
same goal
you can also mix and match you can use
the uh the property-based testing to
generate new inputs and then you can
verify the neighborhood of these inputs
uh you can also encode the
transformation in a
property uh that you can give to a
formal approver so you can
the the
there are different ways that these
things can be combined
and you can also use a simulator so some
people
use a
simulator or generator as a
specification so we have we had an
expression of interest actually that
that was uh around that and so what they
did basically is use a generative
adversarial network to generate a whole
bunch of images and then what they do is
they consider the the network as a
specification so what they say is all
the images that can be uh generated by
this network
my network knows how to how to deal with
them
um so the the verification problem that
i showed before where you had the
program and the specification the
specification itself becomes the model
as well and you have two models to
verify in conjunction
uh so this can work
uh right now they only use mnist i think
if i remember correctly i i'm sorry i've
forgot the name of the team that does
this so if you are here just raise your
hand
right now it's for small uh
use cases only but as i said before
scalability doesn't com is not a really
big roadblock that scares the former
methods community because we
we we've dealt with these problems
before but the question is
in the case of you take images and you
verify the neighborhood around images
you can actually look at the images and
you can
spend some time selecting the right
images
that are wide enough to cover your
distribution et cetera uh
but for for a generative adversary
network
i don't know if you can
i mean the question still still remains
whether or not that can serve as a
specification
right so this is as a side note all the
things that i'm talking about uh i'm
talking about in the in the con
on focused on the validation so once the
model is is present
how can you validate it
but all this can also be well yeah all
of this can can also or the
transformations of this can can also be
used in the in previous steps of the
conception so for example in the
selection of data you can use the
property-based testing to generate data
to train your network so this will be
ec5 if you remember the
the subprograms that we talked about
before
you can also use
some of these things to train your
network and you can even use the
intervals that i talked about before to
actually
train your network not on individual
inputs but our neighborhood whole
neighborhood around the around the
inputs
that
has problems of scalability but it gives
you a robust by design network at the
end
uh so now the methods i'm just going to
talk about one which is absolute
calculation and i'm going to say high
level
and abstract contemplation is used to be
able to verify properties on whole
inputs on whole intervals of inputs so
for example if you have an x that is
between a and b
and a y between c and d
you want to to verify the program on all
the inputs that are between these bounds
so what you do is you propagate these
intervals through all the operations of
the of the of the program
here you have the example of addition
which is the simplest one
multiplication is a bit harder then you
got into loops and conditions and it
gets really messy
you can also use more sophisticated
domains than just intervals of course
and the the the one thing you can do is
also to uh intersect the these domains
the different domains uh regularly to be
to keep them as refined as possible
because the goal is to say as precise as
possible because this is an over
approximation so what you can have is
uh if you're not precise enough
i'll say that in a minute the goal of
this is
suppose the concrete or the real
behavior of your program is the yellow
the yellow part what you do with
absolute contemplation is you over
approximate it
uh conservatively so that if the over
approximation is in a safe space you
know that the real program is also in a
safe space
the
flip side of this is if you're not
precise enough so this is why i talked
about before about the several domains
that
intersect with each other to stay as
processed as possible because if you're
not precise enough then you can have
false alarms meaning the the
the system cannot conclude that the
abstraction abstraction is safe uh but
the concrete pro program itself can be
actually safe
so the goal is to try to over
approximate
stay as processed as possible but of
course the more you you try to stay
precise the more costly it gets
and so you have to play with this
trade-off a bit
and you can use the same for neural
network so
for example if you take as an as an
input
this eight uh and you can encode all the
possible uh
modification that this input can have
around a certain uh with a certain
distance
uh and then you can
propagate all these uh intervals through
the network the whole because the
network is just addition multiplications
um and non-linearity
which is a real problem uh and then at
the end
if the over approximation is still in
the
right classification that you want then
you know that the real
execution of the neural network will
always give the right result
if not you're not sure that it's you
don't have a guarantee it doesn't
necessarily mean that it won't work but
you don't have a guarantee and in some
cases you can actually generate a
full counter example
but that's that's
can be sometimes costly
now i could give you a lot of references
for formal methods applied to a neural
network i put here also symbolic
execution that can be used there are
also smt solvers that can be used and
mixed integer programming a lot of
things can be used but
um you can just go read the the reports
that we did this work already in le
grand de fe
we analyzed the state of the yard so you
can re read the report that should be
public right yep
um
no no not public okay then
i'll i'll
keep this longer but there are a lot of
other
references
i should have asked before
and as a side note this is not a
complete picture because
when you when you deal with software you
don't just deal with the source code you
have to deal with all the compilation
steps
all the way to the machine
and so for example there are people who
showed that even if you verify your
neural network if you don't verify it at
the level of the floating point encoding
it can still have problems
and at cea we try to cover these these
things we have tools that deal with even
the binary level we have been sec
we have also people looking at the
verification of
paralyzed programming et cetera so you
have to keep this in mind this is
outside of my talk but you have to also
keep this in mind
now for the real world example how many
times
five ten minutes okay so the real world
example more in line failures um
basically in the oil drilling uh you
instead of using very big platforms that
you put in place that are fixed that
don't move what you can do is uh
have a floating platform so the floating
platform
moves from well to well when the world
is
exploited it goes to another well uh and
they're basically just very very big
ships and you absolutely need them to
stay in place so uh because of course if
they move when there's a storm then
pipes can break and oil spills can
happen etcetera so what they do is fix
them
more than basically with anchor chains
and the chains are enormous i mean a
single link of the chain is as big as a
human being and they can be more than a
kilometer long and so what you need is
to check if these lines can break
so monitor these lines
because sometimes the break can happen
at the end of the line so you don't
really see it when you look at the chain
so what you could do is fix detectors on
the chain but any detector that you use
that is close to salt water doesn't last
more than a year so you have to find
another way
and so what they did is rely on the
motions of the of the of the platform
uh long-term motions relying on on dual
gps and they give that to the to a
neural network and the neural network
they train the neural network with
different weather conditions different
sea conditions cetera different
moonlight tensions etc and and that
neural network can help them detect
mooring line failures in different
groups
and once they had that they came to us
to verify the robustness of
there are many properties that i cannot
talk about and results i cannot talk
about but one of the things that i can
talk about is the the robustness with
sensory
sensory sensitivity so
the gps location was correct with a
certain error and so what we did is
include that error in the in the
analysis and at the end we were able to
show that the system was more or less
robust
in that in that error error parameters
so still a long way ahead challenges uh
one of the big challenges that we have
is that in a software
human written software traditional
software what you can do is divide it
into smaller and smaller bits this is
also something that that was mentioned
this morning smaller and smaller bits
each bit with the
bits meaning function model modules etc
each with a specification and you can
prove them separately and once you prove
them separately you can have
you can prove the glue that holds them
together and you have a proof of your
software and if at some point you need
to change the function
because you found a better algorithm
that is more efficient or something you
only need to redo that particular proof
and then you have the whole system again
with ai things are different uh of
course so with symbolic ai it can still
be done we have a we have a
framework called colibrix where
basically you have separate bricks for
each of the domains that you might use
and the goal is for us to be able to
basically if a partner comes and say i
have an application that only needs
floating points and arrays then we pick
the floating points domains propagation
labeling etc and we do the same for
array we put them together and you have
a tailor-made
solver
so you can still do the same thing
because they're separate bricks
with machine learning i don't know how
to do that yet
we'll we're looking at some
some things but for example if you if
you trained your your neural network on
faces and then you wanted to
retrain it so that you can also
recognize faces with mask
how can you do it without
losing the properties that you've
already proven right now the best thing
you can do is just reprove the system
uh it would be good if you could you
know detect the the properties that you
no longer satisfy
another challenge is a bit social uh
which is uh with traditional software uh
a company invests a lot of time and
money into writing a you know a system
uh and so when a new let's say
programming language arises like rust uh
i don't know adf or tales or they're not
going to say we're going to recode all
our system in
they're going to think twice about
recoding all the system in rust because
they invested so much time
with machine learning if there is a new
very efficient model that is very
different from the current models uh all
you need is of course machine learning
experience but
the heavy lifting is made by the machine
that trains once you selected your data
you already have your data you can redo
the whole thing
and so if if you design tools that only
deal with the current models without
trying to look ahead at the models that
can be used in industry like recurrent
networks and graph networks
you might be left behind
and of course you have the
other challenges
scalability we're trying to look at
clever heuristics polarization
uh we also try to focus on community
building because that's that's also what
lifts all the community
and we also try to invest time in the
formation formation
through university courses tutorials
with indriya as well tutorials and
conferences etc and so to conclude i can
summarize the whole thing the whole
fourth
or five first points by
a lot of challenges towards the former
methods application but we're working on
it and we have very good signs
this is why we're optimistic
and confused
i think really an excellent environment
for this because we have access to all
these industrial partners with
industrial real life k use cases that we
can work on and we also have academic
partners to to to work with us on the
scientific side
thanks
[Applause]
thank you very much we we spend
we take five minutes for questions so i
already see one here the time needed for
the microphone to reach you i will ask
you one question but then you will be
second
so this afternoon we have to work three
workshops but two are maybe related to
what you say one is on uh robustness so
of course it's right here the second is
on explainability so what are
any link between formal methods and
explainability uh
there can be yes so we have a thesis
with lee mag
at seva a very brilliant guy
what we're trying to do is use the
explainability
in formal methods so basically rely on
but again we're going to need to take as
granted the explainability part right
once we have that we can use that in in
formal methods that's one thing that
we're looking at right now yeah
okay so thank you for talking
for you from there
so you know that uh in earnest we are in
love with formal methods you use it a
lot and i'm part of this team that is
using the formal method
just one question i come back on your
slide when you compare i would say
legacy formal method with with the new
one
and in fact you you say that on your
side you present that
in legacy format method in fact you you
are analyzing the c code or the binary
code and for
actually for formal metal and artificial
intelligence you are analyzing the model
that is not the the final code
so my question is why
we are doing that and are we able to
analyze the infinitely the c chord or
the binary because at the end what is in
inside the target this is not the model
this is the c code
so
what what does it mean to analyze only
the model and what are the consequences
on the proof that you are able to pull
and the second part is at the end do you
think that we will be able to analyze
the binaries or c code for artificial
intelligence thank you
i'm an optimistic guy so i'm going to
say yes to the second question uh so the
first question the reason we start with
the model is because it's the first the
entry point uh this is why we also have
a pharmacy for the c code is because you
also need to to verify the
the the the source code the the thing is
you have a very high level specification
that you divide into smaller and smaller
specification
that you connect with different bits of
the code and then this specification you
need to also translate it into smaller
and smaller specifications to go to the
to the binary code uh
i don't see how you can
forget about the first part the model
part and the source code part and just
go to the binary because it is efficient
if or it is useful to go from the high
level to the lower level going through
separate steps this is also why we have
separate steps of compilation because
each step can do
things right there you have yeah
yes of course yes
so exactly people looking online so if
you please repeat what the question so
basically you just said that you also
need to deal with the low level i'm i'm
agreeing with that but
this and and we have people working on
that as well and a lot of people are
working on that as well and it is
absolutely an important thing
but you also need to verify the model so
right now the problem of verifying the
model is not completely solved
and with as i said we're working on on
the verification of parallel programming
uh the binary step of ai is not yet on
[Music]
we are thinking of it of course but we
don't have time to dedicate to it now
the thing is if you can't verify the
model
the other steps are
you know kind of lost right you have to
be able to check each step that you make
but i agree with you that you without
that without that last step
a lot of what we're doing
is
dodgy
yes so i think we are not
we are going to get rid of dios 178
anyhow
but my question is to complement to to
complete your your your challenges
you mentioned that
one option was to build a specification
using a neural network that would be the
the specification in the end but
being in the industry uh you know that
specifications are um
texts and documentations on which people
have to agree
and discuss those specifications so
uh my question would be your model is
going to be a model of what
a specification of what
that's this is why i said the the
can we keep the slides
i'm not steve jobs
thanks
uh this is why i said i
people are looking at this and the the
thing is
it is
at the beginning of a discipline it is
nice to keep all options open but this
is one of the options that doesn't
satisfy me either because the
specification that you start from our
text and you have to agree on them et
cetera
the people that look at this
try to find so basically what what can
happen what is possible to happen is
that the the problem of ai brings in
forces us to to find new ways of
specifying if that happens then this
might be useful if that doesn't if we
can find a way to deal with
specification without relying on this of
course we don't we won't rely on this
the thing is
if you if you if you don't have
if you don't have a way to specify your
perceptive system
i don't know how to go from there
so right now we're keeping all the
options open uh i'm i'm not working on
on the the gan the gun thing uh but i
think
i'm i'm always so
fundamental research can sometimes
branch into different things that die
off but it's very important to look at
these things as well
yeah thank you for the very interesting
talk and uh very great to understand uh
on this slide i think you showed that
you are using the
the distribution um to
uh to assess or formally assess the
model yes and um my question is how do
you
construct this distribution space for
example if you take an image do you take
image metadata do you take
embeddings from a neural network or how
do you construct this distribution
you so to construct a distribution you
basically take whatever the network will
be run on so if the network will also
have metadata as an input then you also
use that yes
if if it's just the images anonymize
data and stuff then you just use images
it depends basically depends on what the
model is going to be used on afterwards
well thank you for the presentation
um
a property that i find to be interesting
in robust uh sorry in people working on
robust optimization is the ability to um
in addition to to specifying the the or
to verify some property in addition to
optimize the parameters to be able to
fulfill fulfill these properties
is there any is there any way to do the
same with formal verification
like you cannot you for instance you
cannot reach the verification
step at the moment but if you change
these parameters this way then it's
going to work
so the the
thanks
uh what was it was this this is i think
that you're you're talking about this
when i when i talked about the intervals
or so the absolute interpretation that i
talked about the fact to that you can
propagate intervals you can do it during
reigning
trainings or you can you can train your
network on intervals
uh
that way if you wanted to be robust
with a certain
perturbation parameter you can use
training to do that but of course the
other parameters are still are still
important the efficiency the precision
et cetera
i was talking about the parameters of
the model can you optimize the model
in such a way that it verifies some
properties
sure yes you can also you can also have
a have a so i didn't mention this but
there are people working on i think it's
called differentiable logic where you
you you train your model on a
specification you you give it a logical
formula and you and you
you tell it to train with
with this logical formula in mind so
that at the end it verifies it so yeah
you can do that too so then this this
will be the last question so that then
we move to the next sequence
yeah thank you i'm i'm indeed from cap
germany engineering
um i have a question regarding
your methods like to extend the
distribution
and you're using the data augmentation
methods
and as i understand if i understand
correctly it's like a posterior method
to verify that you're in the domain
but
[Music]
wouldn't you as a data engineer like
when you create your model try to have
all this distribution
already doing training so any data you
can you are able to generate you would
try to train your model on and it would
already be inside that actual
distribution so the actual problem is
more data that you are not able to
generate no
that's like this conflict
first of all i'm not a data engineer but
this is this is the the thing i talked
about the the
for validation i think one thing that is
important is to try to see if your
network can generalize to things that it
didn't see if you include all your data
you you generate and you include all
your properties
of robustness in the training then how
would you that becomes of the universe
of things that it knows and how can you
test then that it can generalize this is
this is the reason why we have
validation sets in in training right
here you need something that it didn't
see
uh if you if you if you put everything
you generate in the training then you
might have a but it's something that
actually is interesting to me i want to
i don't have the time but
one thing that that i really want to
know is exactly how much it affects
the the the system if you do that with
the the the trade-offs you can find
between using it at the training and at
the validation uh the type of uh
transformation you you can use the can
you use just different um
distance of perturbation for each of the
steps how can that affect the robustness
of the system as a whole that's that's
actually very i think very interesting
but
fortunately i don't have the time to to
look at that right now
okay so for the other the remaining
questions you will talk directly to zach
you're staying here
yeah thank you very much thank you again
[Music]